* Anschwellender Trommelwirbel *
Die Ecole hoteliere de Lausanne
gehört zu den renommiertesten
Handelsschulen
für die Hotelindustrie.
2'800 Studenten aus über 110 Nationen
streben an der EHL nach Exzellenz,
Können und Selbstbewusstsein.
Wir begleiten
drei Studenten im Vorbereitungsjahr
und zwei am Ende des Studiums.
Alexandre Charlaix, 18 Jahre alt.
Mit seiner Matura in der Tasche
geht er in das Vorbereitungsjahr.
Emma Pittet ist 21, wurde
in der Genferseeregion geboren
und beginnt ihr Studium
an dieser internationalen Schule.
Genau wie Alexandre Attia,
19 Jahre alt.
Der Sohn eines Hoteliers geht mit
Selbstvertrauen ins erste Semester.
Annina von Falkenstein.
Mit 21 beginnt sie
ihr vorletztes Studienjahr.
Die junge Baslerin strebt
nach nichts weniger als Exzellenz.
Afrim Beqa, 27,
startet sein letztes Semester.
Der energetische Afrim möchte
selbstständiger Unternehmer werden.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Letztes Mal in "Die Hotelfachschule":
Alexandre
zeigt grosses Selbstvertrauen,
als ob das erste Semester
für den Sohn eines Hoteliers
nur eine Formalität wäre.
Im Herbst gehen wir an
die Europameisterschaft in Rumänien.
Ich werde möglicherweise ein,
zwei Tage nicht hier sein können.
Ein wichtiges Jahr,
aber ich bin bereit.
Emma hat auch aus eigener Tasche
bezahlt, um die EHL zu absolvieren.
Sie gibt alles für
den Start in das Vorbereitungsjahr.
Und wenn sie jemals die Werte
des wirklichen Lebens vergisst,
erinnert sie ihr Vater daran.
Ich vertraue meiner Tochter,
dass sie kritisch bleibt
gegenüber dieser
"Wir sind die Besten"-Einstellung.
Trotz seines jungen Alters
ist Alex bereit,
sich strengen Formen anzupassen.
Unter dem ironischen Blick
seiner Mutter, einer Stylistin,
probiert er
seine erste Arbeitskleidung an.
Es ist aufregend, aber auch
ein wenig unheimlich. Ein Abenteuer.
Annina beginnt ihr vorletztes
Semester mit der Ernsthaftigkeit,
die sie auszeichnet:
Über den Lehrplan hinaus
multipliziert sie ihre Aktivitäten
an der Schule.
Freizeit ist nicht ihre Priorität.
Und so präsentiert sie
als Botschafterin die EHL in Paris.
Für die vier Jahre
kostet es 155'000 Fr.
Suisses?
Afrim beendet seine Laufbahn
an der EHL. Er sprudelt vor Ideen.
Aber der Schwerpunkt
liegt auf der Gruppendiplomprüfung,
dem Studenten-Businessprojekt SBP.
Wir erfahren gleich, worum es geht.
Es ist mein letztes Projekt.
Das ist aufregend.
Guten Morgen. Als Erstes: Zeitlich
funktioniert es hier gar nicht.
Um 7.25 Uhr sollt ihr erscheinen
und um 7.30 Uhr
sollt ihr alle bereit sein.
Jetzt haben wir schon 5 Min.
verloren. Wie viele seid ihr? 16?
5 Min. mal 16 gibt mehr als 2 Std.
Also bitte.
Pünktlich zu erscheinen und euch
dann 5-10 Min. vorzubereiten,
wird kein Chef in einem
Unternehmen tolerieren. Verstanden?
(Alle) Ja, Chef.
Bei der EHL wird jeder Workshop
bewertet und alles zählt.
Und das Verhalten des Schülers?
Es macht die Hälfte der Note aus.
Mehr als 15 Min. Verspätung:
minus ein Punkt.
Eine berechtigte Abwesenheit, selbst
bei Krankheit: minus ein Punkt.
Alex wird eingeführt
in die Freuden der Raumpflege.
Je crois que c'est bon.
Il n'y a personne.
Haben Sie zweimal geklopft?
- Ja, ähm, nein, nicht zweimal.
Housekeeping.
So, alles gut.
Duschkopf, Lavabo,
Wasserhahn, Duschwand.
Oh Mist,
kann ich das kurz hier lassen?
Legen Sie es auf den Rand
oder oben auf den Schrank!
Wenn da Haare sind,
werfe ich sie in den Abfall?
Wenn da was ist?
Haare. Alles so schmutzig hier.
Es ist der erste Tag. Es gibt Leute,
die so was noch nie gemacht haben.
Das weiss man nie,
wenn man eine Gruppe hat.
Es gibt einige, die Erfahrung
von zu Hause haben und schnell sind.
Andere haben noch nie geputzt.
Das wird sehr kompliziert,
denn sie brauchen viel Zeit
und haben keine Ahnung.
In den ersten sechs Monaten
erfahren die neuen Studenten
alle praktischen Aspekte
der Hotelleriewelt -
von der Reinigung der Campus-Zimmer
bis zum Service,
vom Spültisch
bis zum Gourmetrestaurant.
Ich weiss,
dass man es genau machen muss.
Es wäre einfacher,
wenn das Ganze amüsanter wäre.
Ist es nicht amüsant genug?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Es gibt Besseres.
In welchem Sinne?
Es geht ja nicht nur um Spass.
Ja, Sie haben Recht,
es ist ja eine Arbeit.
Sie sehen,
wie anstrengend dieser Beruf ist.
Am frühen Morgen hat Emma
die Konditormütze aufgesetzt.
Ich liebe das Kochen.
Salzig oder süss?
Beides.
Übrigens, ich habe eine Frage:
Was ist die beste Art,
die Zitronentorte zuzubereiten?
Meiner Meinung nach
ist die beste Methode im Wasserbad.
So mache ich es.
Und dann giesst du es in die Torte.
Du erhältst so die beste Textur.
Danke. Könnten Sie mir das kurz
zeigen?
Ratschläge, von denen sie
nur zu Hause profitieren kann:
In den Campus-Zimmern
ist Kochen verboten.
Es sieht einfach aus,
ist es aber nicht.
Die Creme muss einwandfrei sein,
darf keine Klumpen haben,
sodass sie
sauber aufgetragen werden kann.
Absolute Meisterschaft, Perfektion -
die EHL zieht
die prestigeträchtigsten Dozenten an,
wie der
berühmte dreifarbige Kragen zeigt.
Der Kragen ist eine Auszeichnung
für einen Wettbewerb in Frankreich.
Ich habe ihn 2015 gewonnen,
im Bereich Patisserie.
Es ist ein Wettbewerb,
der viel Arbeit kostet.
Ich habe zwei Jahre dafür trainiert.
Es ist köstlich.
Man schmeckt Cassis und Marronen.
Es ist exzellent.
Ein wahres Vergnügen.
Er hat sich hier gut überlegt,
wo man überall putzen muss,
wo man normalerweise Staub findet.
Haben Sie an die Tischbeine gedacht?
Alexandre?
Verzeihung, ja?
Vergessen Sie die Tischbeine nicht.
Staub wischen, Flecken reinigen,
das ist körperliche Arbeit.
Alex erlebt das täglich 8 Std.,
fast wie ein echter Profi.
An diesem Morgen muss Emmas Team
800 Stück Süssgebäck herstellen.
In der Produktion
ist keine Verzögerung erlaubt,
die Mittagspause
duldet keine Verspätung.
Das ist der Schokoladen-Crumble.
Man muss darauf achten,
dass er immer knusprig ist,
mit Kokosnussbutter,
äh, Kakaobutter.
Oh mein Gott,
ich habe alles vollgemacht.
Merci.
Ich füge hier noch Schokolade hinzu.
* Dumpfe, energiegeladene Klänge *
Alexandre
stürzt sich aufs gesunde Essen.
Er bietet den Service
in der Sektion Wellness an,
die glutenfreie
Pasta alle vongole anbietet.
Wie heissen Sie? Alexandre?
Freut mich.
Ich zeige Ihnen ein erstes
Beispiel für meinen Kollegen,
der eine Portion essen wird.
Wir werden zusammenarbeiten.
Perfekt. Schalotten und Knoblauch.
Den habe ich am Morgen zubereitet.
Wenn es zu heiss ist,
drehst du etwas runter.
Dann die Muscheln rein.
14 pro Portion.
Hier sind noch Gewürze.
Je mets un petit peu d'aneth,
du persil et de la ciboulette ...
Mittags speisen fast 2'000 Studenten
und Mitarbeiter vor Ort.
Sie haben max. 45 Min. Pause.
Für Alexandre
steht Effizienz auf der Speisekarte.
Jetzt ist alles klar, oder?
(Mann) Du musst dir einiges merken.
Er erklärt alles.
Schwierig ist es ja nicht.
Ich muss mir ja nur
die Reihenfolge der Zutaten merken.
* Entspannte Klänge *
In ihrem vorletzten Semester
geniessen Annina und ihre Gruppe
die Freuden des Managements.
Vermögensverwaltung, Marktanalyse
oder reines Marketing -
Theorie umgesetzt in Praxis.
Das ist Woche 13, jetzt ist Woche 7,
wir haben noch sechs Wochen.
Wir besprechen unser Projekt,
das Hotel Asset Management.
Es ist ein Thema im Lehrplan
des fünften Bachelorsemesters.
Wir müssen Pläne
und Projekte realisieren
und eine Analyse
eines Hotels in Berlin machen.
Es ist eine gute Übung,
um zu wiederholen,
was wir bereits im Unterricht
gelernt haben.
Es ist auch eine gute Vorbereitung
für die Prüfung,
aber es braucht auch viel Zeit.
Wir sind 300 Studierende
im Semester,
und wir machen alle mehr
oder weniger das gleiche Projekt.
Das bedeutet,
dass wir die besten sein müssen.
Es ist ein Konkurrenzkampf.
Der Lehrer hat gesagt, dass diese
Firma viele neue Angestellte sucht.
Das ist
eine weitere Motivation für uns.
Wir werden ja sehen.
Je mehr Fortschritte die Schüler
in ihrem Studium machen,
desto härter ist der Wettstreit. Wie
in der Berufswelt, die sie erwartet.
Ein Mittagessen
unter strenger Überwachung.
Monsieur Laurent, der Tempelwächter
des Anstands und des guten Aussehens,
scannt die Versammlung.
Kein Detail entgeht ihm.
Warum tragen Sie diese Hose?
Das ist kein Dresscode.
Oh? Das tut mir
wirklich leid, das wusste ich nicht.
Sie müssen sich umziehen.
Ich gebe Ihnen diese Karte
und beschlagnahme Ihren Badge.
Aber ich lebe ausserhalb des Campus
und habe Prüfungen.
Ich muss Sie heute
in korrekter Kleidung sehen, okay?
Okay, ich ziehe mich um.
- Bis später.
Auf dem Campus wird der Mantel
über dem Arm getragen.
Thank you very much, sir.
Ein Studienbart.
- Rasieren.
Ich studiere hart.
- Der muss weg.
Die Tagesassistentin von
Monsieur Laurent macht Strafaufgaben,
weil sie
einen zu kurzen Rock getragen hat.
Okay? Borderline?
- Borderline.
Ich habe sie gehen lassen.
Sie hat ihre Arbeit gut gemacht,
wir waren aktiv, proaktiv
und haben den Schülern,
die gegen den Dresscode verstossen,
eine Lektion erteilt. Null Toleranz.
Ich sehe mich noch weiter um.
Wie heisst du?
- Melina.
Alex. Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Serviceende für Alexandre,
der sich Zeit nimmt für seine Kundin.
Der Teller ist heiss.
- Es geht schon.
Pass auf!
- Danke.
Der Service ist gut gelaufen.
Ich habe zwei, drei dieser Viecher
verbrannt, aber sonst ist alles gut.
Nach dem Kochen die grosse Reinigung,
Hygiene ist Pflicht.
Alexandre wird
für den Abenddienst zurückkehren.
* Entspannte, jazzige Klänge *
Afrim und seine Gruppe arbeiten
an ihrem Studenten-Businessprojekt,
ihrer Abschlussarbeit,
einem Beratungsmandat.
Sie haben einen Termin am Hauptsitz
der kantonalen Versicherung,
für die sie ein Firmenrestaurant-
modell ausbrüten sollen.
Wir haben hier
einen Saal für uns reserviert.
Es ist cool, hier zu arbeiten.
Ihr wolltet anfangs
etwas ganz anderes machen.
Das passt überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Wir haben noch viel zu erledigen.
Wir werden sehen.
Ich muss in 45 Min. los.
Viel Arbeit
und immer persönliche Projekte -
Afrim muss alles in Einklang bringen.
Das wirst du wissen,
ob du dich beeilen musst oder nicht.
Werde ich mich beeilen,
wenn ich Letzter bin? Nie im Leben.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Machen Sie einen Haufen
mit der Bettwäsche.
Schlüsselmoment des Housekeeping-
Workshops für Alex: die Auswertung.
Hat sich der junge Mann in ein
perfektes Zimmermädchen verwandelt?
Mein Zimmerkollege
und ich schauen jetzt,
dass unser Zimmer sauber bleibt.
Ja, es motiviert mich.
Die anderen ekeln mich an.
Ihr Zimmer ist nicht sauber.
Ich frage mich,
wann die es putzen ...
Es scheint
ihnen scheissegal zu sein.
Zimmer für Zimmer entdeckt Alex
das Konzept des Respekts,
in diesem Fall
für das Dienstpersonal.
Zeigen Sie mir, wie Sie das machen.
Ah, hier haben wir
ein technisches Problem.
Sie haben ja gar nicht geschrubbt.
- Doch.
Mit dieser Bürste?
- Ja, das macht man so.
Und dann benutzen Sie sie
für die Duschwände?
Welches ist denn für Sie
die WC-Bürste?
Auf dem Blatt steht ja nichts von
WC-Bürste. Es steht einfach Bürste.
Ich weiss genau, wie man es macht.
Ich kenne das Verfahren.
Ich mache einfach manchmal
ein paar Flüchtigkeitsfehler.
Passen Sie auf mit den Bürsten,
Hygiene ist hier besonders wichtig.
Beim nächsten Mal
soll es bei Ihnen klingeln:
Achtung, nicht dieselbe Bürste wie
im WC auch in der Dusche benützen.
Ich muss drei Fehler
im Badezimmer eintragen.
Das sind Fehler,
die Sie hätten vermeiden können.
Fautes d'inattention.
- Oui, oui, bon.
Eine Unaufmerksamkeit, die
nicht ohne Konsequenzen bleiben wird.
Ihr habt es bestimmt schon bemerkt:
Heute ist Teamwork ganz wichtig.
So kommen wir besser vorwärts.
Wir haben 5 Min. verloren. Verständ-
lich, es ist ja euer erster Tag.
Aber morgen wird es besser sein.
ihr werdet euch gegenseitig helfen.
(Alle) Merci.
Okay, genug gelacht,
jetzt machen wir diesen Kuchen.
Mein Arm schmerzt
seit ein paar Tagen.
Ich werde
zu einem Spezialisten gehen.
Es geht, aber wir machen
viele Bewegungen mit dem Arm.
Das ist sehr schmerzhaft.
Emma hatte eine Schulteroperation.
Deswegen hat sich
ihr Eintritt in die EHL
schon um ein Semester verzögert.
(Mann) Wie war dein erster Tag?
Es war sehr interessant.
Sie sorgen dafür, dass wir
verschiedene Aufgaben bekommen,
damit wir alle Aspekte kennenlernen.
Ausser, dass der eine Junge uns
die ganze Arbeit weggenommen hat.
* Entspannte, jazzige Klänge *
Ich versuche,
viermal die Woche hierherzukommen,
aber es ist sehr kompliziert.
Es gab zwei Abende, an denen ich
bis 20 oder 21.30 Uhr zu tun hatte.
Eine weitere Herausforderung:
pünktlich erscheinen -
auch nach einem schönen Abend
unter Freunden. Permanenter Druck.
Es ist sehr hart.
Alles wird bestraft.
Wenn du einmal nicht erscheinst,
gibt es einen Minuspunkt.
Beim zweiten Mal zwei Minuspunkte,
und beim dritten Mal
wird die Note annulliert.
Man muss im August wiederkommen
und man muss 300 Fr. für eine noch
schwierigere Nachprüfung bezahlen.
Ich versuche auf jeden Fall,
das zu vermeiden.
D.h. nicht,
dass ich nicht ausgehe.
Aber ich bleibe
schon eher auf dem Campus.
Die Studierenden im Vorbereitungsjahr
sind verpflichtet,
ein Praktikum
für das zweite Semester zu suchen.
Volles Wochenprogramm, unregelmässige
Zeitpläne - wie geht das?
Die EHL organisiert einen grossen
Bewerbungstag, die Karrieremesse.
Da werden viele Leute sein.
Man wird Schlange stehen müssen,
Lebenslauf, Motivationsschreiben
und Businesscard abgeben,
damit man kontaktiert werden kann.
Man soll aber auch deren Karte
mitnehmen, hat man mir gesagt.
Viele vergessen das.
Ich fühle mich nicht dazu bereit,
alleine in meinem eigenen Apartment,
weit weg von meiner Mutter zu leben.
Ich werde mich
noch daran gewöhnen müssen.
Donc, on va y aller, tranquille.
* Jazzige Klänge *
Der grosse Tag der Jobmesse.
160 Unternehmen bieten den Studenten
Praktika aller Art
und den Diplomanden Jobs an.
Willkommen an der EHL.
Ich bin für Ihren Stand
verantwortlich
und helfe Ihnen bei allem, was Sie
brauchen. Rufen Sie mich einfach.
Annina ist EHL-Botschafterin
für vier Unternehmen.
Ich versuche, für die Unternehmen,
für die ich verantwortlich bin,
da zu sein, um sicherzugehen,
dass sie auch zurückkommen.
Ich suche noch keine fixe Stelle
für die Zeit nach meinem Diplom.
Aber ich kenne viele Leute,
die bald ein Praktikum machen,
was eine gute Möglichkeit ist, die
Unternehmen vor Ort kennenzulernen.
Alex hat sich schick angezogen, um in
Genf ein grosses Hotel zu überzeugen.
So könnte er in der Nähe
des Familienkokons bleiben.
Entschuldigen Sie,
stehen Sie hier an?
Wo ist denn das Intercontinental?
- Das ist dort hinten.
Merci beaucoup.
Das sind die Jobs, die hier angebo-
ten werden: Bankett, Room Service.
Am liebsten würde ich
an der Rezeption arbeiten.
Ich bin super im Kontakt mit Leuten.
Vielleicht bin ich aber zu dynamisch
für diesen Job. Wir werden es sehen.
Ich bin sowieso sehr flexibel,
was den Job anbelangt.
Ich habe
meine Businesscard vergessen.
Im Zimmer.
Ich gehe sie schnell holen.
Bin gleich zurück.
Emma geht auf die Suche nach dem
Gral: einem gut bezahlten Praktikum.
Hallo, ich bin im Vorbereitungsjahr
und suche ein Praktikum.
Ich wollte wissen, ob Sie freie
Plätze an der Rezeption haben.
Wir haben unsere Rezeptionsstelle
schon vergeben,
aber wir haben auch noch
eine Rezeption in unserem Spa.
Anstatt Zimmer
werden Sie Behandlungen reservieren.
Vielen Dank. Schönen Tag.
Erster Kontakt
mit dem harten Gesetz der Konkurrenz:
Dieser Platz wird Dutzenden
von anderen Studenten angeboten.
Das wird sicher toll.
Jetzt kriege ich
ein bisschen Lampenfieber.
So viele Leute, nicht nur wir Neuen,
sondern auch die Bachelor 3.
Die sind zwar aus einem
anderen Grund hier, aber trotzdem.
Viele, viele Leute.
Eines ist klar:
Es gibt Konkurrenz.
Die Bachelor-3-Studenten
im zweiten Jahr
erhöhen die Zahl
der zukünftigen Praktikanten.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Und während dieser Zeit ...
... tankt Alexandre Sonne.
(Mann) Hast du aufgehört
mit Volleyball?
Ich musste eine schwere Entscheidung
treffen, eine unglaublich schwere.
Seit ich ein kleiner Junge war,
spiele ich Volleyball.
Seit ich vier oder fünf war.
Ich wollte schon immer
auf höchstem Niveau spielen.
Das habe diesen Sommer
endlich geschafft,
meinen Vertrag unterschrieben.
Leider habe ich in der ersten Woche
an dieser Schule bemerkt,
dass es nicht klappen wird,
jeden Tag zu trainieren.
Jede Woche Prüfungen am Freitag.
Mein Team verreist an Turniere.
Ich würde zwei Tage Kurse verpassen.
Das gibt zwei Punkte Notenabzug.
Ich musste mich entscheiden. Meine
Zukunft ist hier an der Schule.
Volleyball
ist für mich eine Leidenschaft.
(Mann) Was unternimmst du,
um ein Praktikum zu bekommen?
Meine Taktik war: an möglichst
vielen Ständen vorbeigehen,
möglichst viele Spuren hinterlassen,
schauen, wer sich für mich inte-
ressiert, dann meine Wahl treffen.
Dank meines Vaters
kennen mich einige Hotels.
Er hat mit den Direktoren gespro-
chen. Die würden mich nehmen.
Das ist die einfachste Lösung.
Ich fülle die Präsenzliste aus,
um meinen Badge zu erhalten.
Dann drucke ich meinen Lebenslauf
aus und gehe zu den Unternehmen.
Bei Afrim geht es mehr
um Zuzwinkern und Händeschütteln.
Er vernetzt sich,
um Mandate zu finden,
während er auf die Verwirklichung
seiner eigenen Projekte wartet.
Ich stehe nicht unter Druck, Arbeit
zu finden. Das ist ein Vorteil.
Ich kann hier einfach gut Leute
kennenlernen und mit ihnen plaudern.
Während Annina und Afrim
gelassen scheinen,
sind die Jüngsten unter Druck. Ein
Praktikum zu ergattern ist Pflicht.
Sie sollten
schnell unterkommen.
* Entspannte, jazzige Klänge *
Am Wochenende
fährt Annina nach Basel.
Ein Moment der Eisenbahnentspannung?
Nicht doch, sie büffelt.
Ich lerne gerade Französischverben
für die Prüfung am nächsten Samstag.
Hier habe ich
drei verschiedene Stapel.
Der eine ist für die Verben,
die ich zu beherrschen glaube.
Die gelben kann ich teilweise,
teilweise gar nicht.
Die roten sind die schwierigeren.
Das ist mein Lernsystem.
Es ist wie eine Ampel.
So weiss ich,
grün heisst: "Alles gut."
Und die anderen
brauchen noch ein bisschen Übung.
* Jazzige Klänge *
Keine Pause für Emma,
die jeden Sonntag an
einer Tankstelle in Morges arbeitet.
Ich arbeite, um Geld zu sparen
für meine Fahrprüfung,
und um mein Praktikum in der Schweiz
und einen Teil meiner Ausbildung
zu finanzieren.
Ich würde gerne monatlich 1'000 Fr.
beiseitelegen, um nach und nach
meinen Eltern einen Teil
der Studiengebühren zurückzugeben.
Wie alle muss auch sie sich noch
etwas an diese Tätigkeit gewöhnen,
aber sie lernt schnell.
Sie ist sehr dynamisch.
* Ruhige, jazzige Klänge *
Annina
mag das gemütliche Nest der Familie.
Ich freue mich sehr, jetzt zurück
an die Hotelfachschule zu gehen.
Ich habe viele Leute jetzt sechs
oder acht Monate gar nicht gesehen,
obwohl wir vorhatten,
einander gegenseitig zu besuchen.
Das ist halt manchmal nicht einfach.
Lausanne ist grundsätzlich super.
Es ist eine Studentenstadt,
hat viele junge Leute.
Es ist auch etwas multikultureller,
internationaler.
Die Leute sind offener, sind relax-
ter, etwas weniger kleinkariert -
immer pünktlich sein
wie die Deutschschweizer.
Das gefällt mir.
Hallo, Papa.
Annina wollte schon
als kleines Mädchen,
mit acht, neun, zehn Jahren,
im Hotel arbeiten.
Sie machte auch
immer gerne in Hotels Urlaub.
Dort schaute sie sich
immer alles genau an.
Sie sah auch Fehler
und kritisierte sie.
Sie wollte das eigentlich immer.
Sie wohnt sehr gerne zu Hause,
sie war immer gerne zu Hause.
Du erinnerst dich noch
an den Tag, als wir gingen? - Ja.
Als wir gingen.
Das tut jetzt noch ...
Da stand sie dort und ja ...
... heulte. Wir haben fast geheult
und gingen dann.
Das war schwierig.
Aber ich glaube,
es war die richtige Wahl.
Wenn ich sie jetzt höre,
ist es das einzig Richtige.
Anninas Mutter ist Grossrätin
und Präsidentin der Basler
Liberal-Demokratischen Partei.
Auch Anninas Vater
ist politisch tätig:
als Nationalrat und Präsident
der Erziehungsdirektorenkonferenz.
Aber heute Abend ist es der tradi-
tionelle Basler Stadtlauf von Annina,
der die Familie mobilisiert.
* Kirchenglocken *
* Stimmengewirr *
* Jubel *
(Mann) War sie immer schon sportlich?
Es geht. Nein, nicht wirklich.
Sie hat schon immer etwas gemacht.
Aber, sagen wir,
ein grosses Sporttalent war sie nie.
In der Schule
war sie immer sehr gut.
Da war sie immer ambitioniert
und wollte gut sein.
Das ist wichtiger für sie.
Ah, da kommt sie.
Hopp, Annina! Hopp, Hopp!
Alexandre beginnt
den Konditorei-Kurs. So lala.
... la poudre d'amandes ...
... quatre fois.
La farine de mais
est dans le tiroir.
Ich bin heute um 6 Uhr aufgestanden.
Ich muss
meinen Lebensrhythmus ändern.
Bist du bereit?
Mist.
Ich finde die Bäckerei interessant.
Man lernt die Sorgfalt.
Wenn man einen Rechenfehler
bei den Zutaten macht,
funktioniert es nicht. Und wenn man
etwas zu lange backt, verbrennt es.
Man muss lernen,
auf jedes Detail zu achten.
Einerseits ist es toll:
Wir können während des Backens
immer wieder probieren.
Andererseits nervt es mit der Zeit.
Aber man muss es machen,
um alle Berufszweige kennenzulernen
und zu verstehen, wie das geht.
(Mann) Wie macht sich Alexandre?
Na ja,
manchmal gibt er sich sogar Mühe.
Nein, er arbeitet sehr gut, wenn er
sich auf seine Arbeit konzentriert.
Er lässt sich aber schnell
von seinen Kollegen ablenken
und macht dann Faxen mit ihnen.
Monsieur,
die Kollegen machen Faxen mit mir.
Vos camarades viennent vers vous?
Au controle, Claude?
C'est bon, les garcons ...
Alex
steht am Ende des Getränkekurses.
Es geht um seine Note.
Also, billiger Rotwein, Aperitif,
Digestif, oder nichts?
Vorsicht, Falle.
(Flüsternd) Haben die einen
auch keinen Alkohol drin?
(Flüsternd) Alles ist möglich.
* Unverständlich *
Oui. Okay, d'accord.
Sommelierkurs für Emma,
die ihren Dienst im Gourmetrestaurant
der Schule beendet.
Wir müssen noch die Tischdecke
für heute Abend auflegen.
Und das war's schon.
Jetzt sind wir fast fertig.
Von der Mitte dort beginnen.
Horizontal.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Ah, la six.
Mais elle est faite, la six.
Ich habe starke Schmerzen.
Hier und in den Fingern habe
ich ein beunruhigendes Kribbeln.
(Mann) Nimmst du Schmerzmittel?
Ja, täglich etwa vier.
Und in der Nacht auch noch.
(Mann) Kannst du
sonst nicht schlafen?
Nein, ohne geht es nicht.
Wenn ich mich so bewege
und den Arm hebe,
brennt es sofort.
Hat es Ihnen gefallen?
- Ja, sehr.
Was hätten Sie besser machen können?
Das Organisieren
zwischen den verschiedenen Gästen,
z.B. war ich manchmal
zu lange an einem Tisch,
während an einem anderen
auf den Wein gewartet wurde.
Also besser organisieren und
Prioritäten setzen. Einverstanden.
Wenn an einem Tisch Wein und an
einem anderen Wasser serviert wird,
wohin gehen Sie zuerst?
Dort, wo Wein serviert wird.
Da verdienen wir mehr Geld.
Ja, da man für den Wein zahlt
und für das Wasser nicht.
Zweitens, da der Wein immer
vor dem Essen serviert werden muss.
Das ist
die Priorität des Sommeliers.
Und jedes Mal, wenn Wein serviert
wird, müssen Sie genau aufschreiben,
von welcher Flasche
wie viele Gläser serviert wurden.
Es ist ja schön und gut,
viele Gläser zu servieren,
aber Sie müssen sich immer notieren,
was getrunken wird,
wie viele Deziliter
von welcher Sorte Wein.
Sie sind sehr dynamisch und sind gut
im Kontakt mit Kunden. Das mag ich.
Das ist
eine französischsprachige Equipe.
Das gefällt mir. Behalten Sie
diese Ausstrahlung für heute Abend.
Sehr, sehr gut.
Einfach ein bisschen organisierter.
Je vais lui dire ... Je vais parler
de vous. - Oui, merci beaucoup.
Alexandre ist dran mit der Bewertung.
Jedes Detail zählt -
von der Eignung bis zur Einstellung.
Wie schätzen Sie sich ein?
Was denken Sie, wie Sie sich
diese Woche verhalten haben?
Ich denke, während der Schichten
habe ich gute Arbeit geleistet.
Jedoch habe ich mir selbst
gewisse Pausen erlaubt,
die nicht hätten sein müssen.
Für das Team und ...
Das ist es, was ich ansprechen will.
Wenn Sie hier sind, arbeiten Sie
grundsätzlich gut und effizient.
Das war super. Sie halten sich
an die Anweisungen und den Zeitplan.
Die Arbeit, die Sie in der Küche
geleistet haben, war sehr gut.
Aber ich habe ein bisschen das Ge-
fühl, dass Ihnen der Respekt fehlt.
Der Respekt vor uns,
den Lehrpersonen,
aber auch gegenüber den Mitschülern.
Z.B. gestern,
als wir Präsentationen hatten.
Ihre Präsentation war gut,
das steht ausser Frage.
Aber während der Präsentation
der anderen Studenten
haben Sie
mit Ihrem kindischen Verhalten
die Zuschauer und die Präsentatoren
gestört und abgelenkt.
Sie lachten und schwatzten während
der Präsentationen der anderen.
Das tolerieren wir nicht.
Wenn jemand spricht,
wird aufmerksam zugehört.
Das war wirklich nicht top.
Dazu kommt:
Sie essen während der Arbeit.
Sie haben
ein Dessert mitgehen lassen.
Das ist auch nicht in Ordnung,
das sollten Sie wissen.
Und anstatt es zuzugeben,
als ich Sie darauf ansprach,
behaupteten Sie,
es sei für eine bakterielle Analyse.
Das ist einfach frech
und überhaupt nicht professionell.
Es tut mir leid, aber
wir sind alle auf derselben Höhe.
Es ist keiner oben und die anderen
unten. Wir sind alle gleich.
Das mit den Absenzen
ist auch noch ein Problem.
Das zieht Sie auch noch runter.
Immerhin sind Sie heute gekommen.
Sie haben insgesamt
nur einen Minuspunkt und nicht zwei.
Es ist noch nicht alles verloren.
Wenn Sie
in der nächsten Woche alles geben,
können Sie vielleicht noch
auf eine Note über 4 hoffen.
Es ist viel Arbeit
und es geht schnell.
Also geben Sie nicht auf.
Ran an die Arbeit.
Okay? Also viel Glück
und bis später.
Was war das Erste?
Ja, weisser Rum.
Dann hatte ich Whiskey.
Das nächste war Wasser. Und dann
hatte ich irgendeinen Likör.
Das waren Aperitifs.
Ziemlich sicher.
Aber so viel zählt
das ja auch nicht.
Nein, aber das sollte schon reichen.
Es war nicht sehr schwierig.
Wir hatten 1 Std. Zeit
und waren nach 20, 25 Min. fertig.
(Mann) Wo ist dein Mitbewohner?
Der ist noch an der Prüfung.
Wir sind in derselben Gruppe.
Das ist praktisch: So haben wir
fast denselben Stundenplan.
Und er weckt mich am Morgen.
Weil ... das ist nötig.
Wenn wir am Vorabend rausgehen,
ist es am Dienstagmorgen hart,
aufzustehen.
(Mann) Wohin gehst du morgen?
Ich habe bei meinem Chirurgen
einen Termin wegen meiner Schulter.
Er wird mir
eine Kortisonspritze geben,
die sicher zwei Tage lang
schmerzen wird.
Dafür wird es dann besser gehen.
Auch für ein paar Prüfungen
wird es helfen,
wenn meine Schulter schmerzfrei ist.
(Mann) Verlierst du Punkte?
Das wird mich einen Punkt kosten,
auch wenn ich nicht den ganzen Tag
fehle - nur eine Lektion.
Ich verliere einen Punkt.
Das ist schon viel.
Was ist die erste Vorspeise?
Eierparfait.
Was passt dazu?
(Alle) Chardonnay.
Wird es Emma schaffen,
trotz der Schmerzen zu lächeln?
Und die geforderte Reihenfolge
in ihrer Bestellung einzuhalten?
C'est une espece de ...
Mit Trüffelsauce.
... petite tourte,
comme une tarte ...
Welcher Wein passt dazu?
Malbec.
Nein, nein Cabernet.
An der Schule ist das Diktat der
Kleiderordnung um 19.15 Uhr beendet.
Der Moment für Alexandre,
auf seine Woche zurückzuschauen.
Ich denke, ich bin super im Service,
ich bin in meinem Element.
Beim Putzen mache ich schnell ein
paar Witze, aber ich arbeite immer.
Aber es scheint sie zu stören.
Für mich ist das kein Problem.
In jedem Beruf
muss man lachen können,
dann bleibt man professionell.
Meine Arbeit ist gut.
Niemand hat gesagt, dass ich störe.
Die Witze schaden nicht,
ich verbreite nur gute Stimmung.
Aber sie sehen das anders.
Zur Gänseleber empfehlen wir einen
Riesling, wenn Sie Weissen mögen.
Für den Hauptgang
empfehlen wir Chardonnay.
Emma hat korrekt an den Wein
vor dem Hauptgang gedacht,
aber ein bisschen zu früh.
In so einer Situation
ist es am besten,
alle Information zu notieren
und später zurückzukommen,
damit sie
den Aperitif noch geniessen können.
Sehen Sie?
Sonst wird es ein bisschen viel.
Glücklicherweise hat sie rechtzeitig
ihre Bestellzettel ausgefüllt.
Kurz gesagt: Ein Beruf kann nicht
in einer Woche erlernt werden.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Nächstes Mal
in "Die Hotelfachschule":
Der letzte Schultag für mich. Um
7.45 Uhr werden die Kunden kommen.
Wir halten unsere Präsentation
und verlassen dann das Zimmer.
Dann werden wir hereingerufen und
erfahren, ob wir bestanden haben.
Die Prüfungen
haben am Dienstag angefangen.
Es bleibt dieses Wochenende, um mich
auf nächste Woche vorzubereiten.
Fünf Prüfungen an vier Tagen.
Es ist sehr stressig.
Ich werde verhandeln,
um das Praktikum
bei meinem Vater zu machen.
Ich werde sagen, ich habe
in den Ferien dort gearbeitet
und mich im Team wohlgefühlt.
Im Reglement steht, dass Praktika im
Familienbetrieb nicht erlaubt sind.
Sie haben die Prüfung beendet?
Ja, ich habe einiges verwechselt,
aber egal.
Achtung, der Rock ist etwas zu kurz.
Es ist hart, früh am Morgen.
In meinem Kopf sage ich mir:
"Oje, es dauert noch drei Wochen."
Ich freue mich auf die Ferien,
das wird mir guttun.
(Mann) Was hast du heute Abend vor?
Nach Hause gehen
oder trainieren oder ausgehen.
Ich weiss es noch nicht.
Mal sehen, ob ich fit bin und nicht
zu stark nach Fritteuse rieche.